بدأت هذه السلسلة غير العادية من الهجمات
في الساعة 6:30 صباحًا عندما
كانت إسرائيل نائمة مع هذا الوابل الهائل من
الصواريخ المتدفقة من غزة. لاحظ أن
هذا سيكون المستوى الذي
ستضرب فيه صواريخهم البدائية حوالي
ستة أميال أو نحو ذلك ثم تصل
ربما يصل مداها إلى 25 ميلًا، وصواريخهم الأكثر تقدمًا هي تلك
التي يبدو أنها
تعتمد على بعض التكنولوجيا التي
تتجاوزها إيران، كما يقول العديد من رجال المخابرات،
ستصل هنا إلى تل
أبيب، أي على بعد حوالي 45 ميلًا من هنا
مهما كان موقعها.
على الرغم من وجود عدد كبير جدًا منهم، إلا أنه
ليس لدينا إحصاء دقيق، ولكن
يبدو أن العدد بالآلاف
سيكون مهمًا لأن ذلك من شأنه أن
يسهل التغلب على
نظام الدفاع الصاروخي الإسرائيلي ونظام القبة الحديدية
والتأكد من مرور البعض منه.  وحتى لو
تم إيقاف الكثيرين، والأهم من
ذلك، فإن جميع المؤشرات تشير إلى أنها وضعت
الأساس لما حدث بعد ذلك في الساعة
7:40 بعد ساعة و10 دقائق، وذلك
عندما بدأ الجنود المقاتلون المسلحون
بالخروج من غزة إلى إسرائيل، بعضهم عن طريق
هدم الجدران والحواجز  هنا
يأتي البعض جوًا
بالمظلات الآلية والبعض الآخر بالقوارب ويتجولون
هنا، كان هذا شيئًا يشير مرة أخرى إلى
أنه كان هجومًا مخططًا للغاية وسرعان
ما رأيت أشخاصًا يحملون
قاذفات صواريخ وبنادق يركضون في
الشوارع حتى أنهم ذهبوا واشتبكوا مع
القواعد العسكرية حيث كنت  قد يعتقدون أنهم يتوقعون أن
تعطي معظم المعارضة فكرة عن درجة
تخطيطهم للخطة وثقتهم عندما ذهبوا
لمهاجمة الإسرائيليين وبالطبع
رأينا مقاطع الفيديو تلك للمدن
التي تمت مداهمتها بالقرب من تلك المنطقة
حيث شاهدنا  إذا كانت لدينا تقارير عن
أخذ أشخاص كرهائن وقتل أشخاص آخرين، فإن
كل ذلك يتحدث عن هذه
الفكرة ذاتها التي سمعنا عنها منذ
البداية، وهي أن هذا يمثل مستوى
من التخطيط والتنفيذ
أعمق بكثير مما رأيناه عادة من قبل
نحن على بعد حوالي 25 كيلومترًا تقريبًا من
سياج غزة، أسمع
طائرات مقاتلة في السماء فوقي، لقد
سمعنا عدة انفجارات ثقيلة متكررة
قادمة من
اتجاه غزة ويمكنني أن أخبركم بينما كنا
نسير بالسيارة إلى هنا  الأمن مشدد للغاية
أه أفراد الأمن عند
نقاط التفتيش مقفلون حقًا إذا صح التعبير،
ماسكات الأمان على الأسلحة متوقفة
وهذا يخبرك أنهم قلقون
بشأن احتمالية حدوث المزيد من
تسلل حماس بالفعل لقد رأينا مجموعة من أه
قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية  جنود يجوبون
حقل مفتوح هذا الصباح
بمركبة على حافة الحقل مع
غطاء محرك السيارة فوق الصندوق
مفتوح وكذلك الأبواب مفتوحة
كانوا يبحثون لأنهم
قلقون من هذه التسللات
وكان هناك أه في  بلدة أشالون
التي مررنا بها في وقت سابق من هذا اليوم،
كانت هناك واحدة في وقت سابق من هذا الصباح
حيث
أوقفت قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية أربعة من مقاتلي حماس، لذا هذا هو
المشهد هنا، صوت
الطائرات، صوت بعيد يبدو
أنه غارات جوية  وهذا الإجراءات
الأمنية المشددة حتى أننا فقط نقف على جانب
الطريق هنا وسيارتنا متوقفة
على الجانب، وجاء الأمن الإسرائيلي
لفحصنا، لقد خرجنا عن المألوف
هنا جاءوا للتحقق مرة أخرى،
إنهم قلقون بشأن مسلحي حماس  ل